[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: September 6, 2017.
A flash of ultraviolet and
X-ray light erupts from the sun,
sending a burst of
radiation toward Earth.
We call it a solar flare.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: Flares are
huge explosions on the surface
of the sun throwing light
out into the solar system
and absolutely baking
anything in its path.
These are really powerful
events erupting from the sun.
And we are fundamentally
in the line of fire.
NARRATOR: The flare
is so intense it
causes radio blackouts
across the side
of the Earth facing the sun.
And the timing could
not have been worse.
PHIL PLAIT: The problem
was at this time
there were hurricanes
in the Atlantic
bearing down on the Caribbean.
And there were people trying to
get in there and rescue folks.
NARRATOR: Radio communication
between disaster relief teams
goes down for most of the day.
Space weather and Earth weather
combined to create chaos.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: It's not
just an academic exercise.
Your very lifestyle
depends on understanding
how the sun behaves.
We need to be able
to predict what
the sun is going to do next.
And in order to do that, we
need to have eyes on the sun,
as many eyes as we can get.
CONTROL TOWER: 3, 2, 1.
NARRATOR: That's why NASA has
put together an elite unit.
CONTROL TOWER: We have
ignition, and we have liftoff,
liftoff, and liftoff on
an international mission
of solar fittings.
NARRATOR: A fleet of
daring spacecraft.
We humans have
come a long way.
If you go back a
few thousand years,
people were worshipping the sun.
And today, we've built
a fleet of spacecraft
that monitor the
sun 24 hours a day,
observing it from
every angle, predicting
what it's going to do next.
That's nuts.
NARRATOR: Leading
the pack is the Solar
Dynamics Observatory or SDO.
It keeps a telescopic
eye on flares blasting
out from the sun's surface.
24 hours a day, the SDO
probe is on the lookout.
It's constantly vigilant.
PHIL PLAIT: It looks
at the sun at a lot
of different wavelengths
in exquisite detail
so that we can see exactly
what sort of high-energy events
are happening on the sun.
NARRATOR: The record
for the longest service
goes to SOHO, our sentinel
monitoring the sun
and its faint outer atmosphere.
PHIL PLAIT: The Solar
and Heliospheric
Observatory or SOHO is the
old hand at studying the sun.
It's been up there
for 25 years observing
not just the sun itself but
the environment around it.
NINA LANZA: Instead of
looking directly at it,
it actually blocks
out most of the light
so that we can see all
these beautiful structures
that surround the sun.
NARRATOR: And then
there's the new recruit,
the Parker Solar
Probe, our scout
going deep behind enemy lines.
PAUL SUTTER: The
Parker Solar Probe
is going to give us the
closest look at the sun
that we have ever had in
the history of humanity.
We're flying so
close to the sun,
we're flying through the
gases of its atmosphere.
NARRATOR: 29 other craft
make up the fleet each
with their own role to play.
PHIL PLAIT: This
fleet of spacecraft
that we have, the
overall mission is
to observe the sun
scientifically,
learn about its
behavior, but also
importantly to learn about the
effects that it has on Earth.
NARRATOR: Our look-out
probe, the Solar
Dynamics Observatory or SDO,
spots something hellish.
PHIL PLAIT: Today's
forecast for the sun
is predicted to be 10,000
degrees Fahrenheit with winds
of up to 600 miles per
second and a pretty
decent chance of rain.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: You don't
want to be in this rainstorm
because your umbrella
isn't going to help you.
Solar rain isn't water.
It's plasma, hot plasma.
NARRATOR: Rather than a
solid, liquid, or gas,
the entire sun is made up
of a strange fourth state
of matter, plasma.
MICHELLE THALLER: Plasma is just
simply gas that's very hot, so
hot it's lost some
of its electrons
and become electrically charged.
And the wonderful
thing about plasma
is that once it has
that electric charge,
you can direct it
with a magnetic field.
NARRATOR: And the sun has the
most powerful magnetic field
in the solar system.
It twists and flows
through the entire star.
The sun's magnetic field
is incredibly complicated.
There are lots of loops
of magnetic lines coming
out of the sun's surface.
GIBOR BASRI: As you
go above the surface,
the magnetic field begins to
control where the gas can go.
And you get these beautiful
loops and other structures
above the sun that
are just showing you
where the magnetic field is.
NARRATOR: The SDO spacecraft's
jaw-dropping videos
of rain on the sun show
plasma flowing along
huge, looping magnetic field
lines that have punched
through the sun's surface.
PHIL PLAIT: Because the
surface of the sun is a plasma,
and these loops of magnetic
fields are coming out of it,
it draws that plasma up,
which then cools and rains
down as a plasma rain.
NARRATOR: Tracking these
loops of magnetic field
and plasma could help
explain solar flares.
And it could give
us some warning.
September 2017.
Minutes before the devastating
mid-hurricane radio blackout,
our solar look-out
spotted an explosion
on the surface of the sun.
PHIL PLAIT: Suddenly, you have
this tremendous flow of energy
and an explosive release of it.
And we call this a solar flare.
This is SDO's specialty
of observation.
NARRATOR: The craft
tracked the magnetic loops
above the sun's surface.
They were highly unstable.
SDO takes very
detailed pictures
of where the flows are.
You can actually see gas
flowing from one place.
And you can see the-- you
can see the magnetic loops.
PHIL PLAIT: This magnetic flux
loops are kind of like wires
carrying electricity.
When they're on their
own, they're fine.
But if they get too close, they
can connect and short circuit,
and then you get a
tremendous release of energy.
The Ghostbusters were
really on to something.
Don't cross the streams.
NARRATOR: The contact between
magnetic loops released an epic
explosion of high-energy light.
This radiation altered
our planet's atmosphere.
Radio waves jammed,
causing blackouts
at the worst possible moment.
PHIL PLAIT: Solar flares
are happening on the sun
90 million miles away.
Who cares, right?
Well, think of it this way.
A really good solar flare could
be the equivalent of, oh, say,
10 million hydrogen
bonds going off.
How's that sound?
Solar flares happen a lot,
and they do affect us.
They have affected
us in the past,
and they will again
in the future.
NARRATOR: But the sun's
twisting magnetic fields
do more than just disrupt
our communications.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI:
When we see flares,
we got to keep an
eye out on those.
But sometimes, there's
something even bigger.
NARRATOR: The sun launches
huge clouds of plasma
across the solar system.
PHIL PLAIT: All of
that material can
come to the Earth and
really mess things up here--
blow out our power grid, destroy
our satellites, even physically
harm our astronauts in orbit.
NARRATOR: Can the solar
fleet safeguard Earth?
[MUSIC PLAYING]